samedi des croissez le tiques des
nationalistes se révolutionnaires des
cagoules et des masques noirs ont défilé
à Paris sous la bannière du comité du 9
mai en hommage à militant du groupe
pétaniste l'œuvre française décédée en
94 des images terrifiantes alors qu'un
assistant parlementaire a été passé à
tabac par cette même extrême droite une
semaine plus tôt cette manifestation n'a
pas été interdite car selon le préfet de
police elle ne constituait pas un risque
de troubles à l'ordre public elle a donc
été autorisé et encadrée par la police
comme à chaque année bien que ces
manifestants étaient tentés de
dissimuler leur identité nous ne sommes
pas dupe nous serons toujours les
reconnaître même sous les tissus les
plus sombres les ennemis de la
République vous préférez vous en prendre
à ceux qui battent le pavé à visage
découvert pour défendre leurs droits à
la retraite et à la démocratie plutôt
qu'à des néonazis vu en effet ce que
nous avons eu dans les rues de Paris et
vous avez parfaitement madame la député
raison de m'interpeller si vous vendez
sur ce point
j'ai donné comme instruction au préfet
de police que tout militants
d'ultra-droite ou d'extrême droite où
tout association aux collectif à Paris
comme partout sur le territoire national
qui déposera des manifestations dans ce
sens que vous avez décrit prendra les
préfets prendront des arrêtés
d'interdiction et nous laisserons donc
les tribunaux jugés doivent savoir si la
jurisprudence permettront en effet de
tenir ces manifestations
je veux dire par ailleurs que si il y a
eu s'il y a eu des s'il y a eu des
violences qui ont été commis vous avez
parlé d'un attaché parlementaire aucune
plainte à ma connaissance et celle du
préfet de police a été déposé je vous
encourage à faire déposer ses plaintes
le plus rapidement possible pour que la
police puisse faire des enquêtes et je
rappelle que c'est bien notre
gouvernement qui pour les œuvres qui
pourra le varium qui pour Bordeaux
nationaliste qui pour génération
identitaire avant dissous des groupes
d'extrême droite qui était là depuis
parfois plus de 30 ans sur le territoire
national
[Applaudissements]